est-ce que vous aviez toujours sur appel
à projet déjà rencontré
certains des lauréats avant même le la
création du fond Marianne est-ce que
vous aviez eu des échanges ah oui avec
certains vous l'avez dit Monsieur aussi
fait oui et avec reconstruire le commun
à ma connaissance monsieur rapporteur je
n'ai pas reçu les responsables de
l'association reconstruire le commun on
pourrait tout à fait honnête avec vous
j'ai pas en tête la totalité des noms ou
des visages des gens qui ont pris part à
ce projet puisque j'ai cru comprendre
qu'il y avait des porteurs de projets et
des prestataires ou des bénévoles au
sein du projet qui était intervenues ce
que je peux dire c'est que j'ai pas de
relation antérieure ou personnelle avec
elle ou eux mais je peux vous certifier
de les avoir jamais croisé dans quelques
endroits que ce soit ou même ni même je
ne sais pas si je les ai reçus sous
d'autres casquettes en tout cas j'ai pas
souvenir de les avoir reçus mais ça veut
pas dire que que ce soit impossible
reconstruire le commun fait partie le
président Arnal vient de l'évoquer de
des associations qui ont reçu de fortes
dotations c'est une association qui
était de création récente puisque elle
avait été créée en toute fin d'année
2020 et que même le versement le
préversement de 39000 euros j'appellerai
le l'appui à la création
avait été versée comment dirais-je au
tout début de l'année 2021 on a parlé de
l'uspm sur le manque d'expérience
finalement des sommes importantes dans
les deux cas sur des associations
US EPM avec un petit budget convenance
50000 euros une reconstruire le commun
une association toute nouvelle portée
sur les fonds bâtissements avec le
soutien de l'État 39000 euros à qui vous
avez attribué donc des
montants importants des subventions Sana
provoqué
pas d'alerte ça n'a pas provoqué
d'alerte particulière au sein de votre
équipe on va parvenir sur les
normissimes mais parce que comme ils
obtiendront quand même et même davantage
que les 300 000 et reconstruire le
commun il y a il y a des il y a des
trous dans les mailles
est-ce que vous pouvez du coup rajouter
la question de Monsieur Hublet à ce
stade
dans le même dans le même domaine oui
bien sûr
monsieur par vous répondre le projet du
fond Marianne c'est aussi et c'est
pourquoi nous faisons aussi cet appel à
projet au-delà de la volonté d'être
transparent à ce moment-là c'est de
faire émerger aussi de nouveaux acteurs
et justement de tâcher de ne pas
travailler qu'avec celles et ceux qui
sont connus du cpdr le but c'est de
toucher la jeunesse sur les réseaux
sociaux et donc de pouvoir aussi
soutenir des acteurs émergents parce
qu'il y a un caractère un peu innovant
ou expérimental à se contredours je mets
des guillemets des précautions
républicain
et donc moi j'ai pas souvenir d'avoir
été informé ou alerté sur les 39 ke que
demande reconstruire le commun
il y a un montant de subvention qui je
comprends est lié aux besoins de
recrutement ou de formation aux médias
en tout cas c'est ce que je recoupe
aujourd'hui dans les dans les documents
mais je ne prends pas part et je n'ai
pas d'alerte sur le montant de la
subvention pour reconstruire le commun